hey thank you please faithful people
stop we got to get this in before curfew
that's right big week for us here in LA
we were upgraded from quarantine to
curfew
perfume how does that even work when
you're already on lockdown remain even
further in your homes Jesus I mean last
week we finally reopened stores this
week we burnt them down you know that
big earthquake that we've been waiting
for here forever in LA I'm expecting
that we'll hit next week and then the
alien invasion and by the way if the
aliens do come please take me with you
probe my ass all you want just get me
the [ __ ] out of here
[Applause]
yeah it's been quite a week now the
media always says that 95% of the
protesters have been peaceful which is
true true and of course I think as all
right-thinking people would agree for a
completely just and righteous cause but
then they show hopefully the violence on
TV because some individuals will always
use protests as an excuse to foment
chaos and hate but enough about the
Republicans there's also some looters
out there and I tell you no businesses
are really safe now I've seen targets
hit and auto zones the Apple Store Sears
was not looted even the looters were
like yeah nothing in there it's very sad
but yeah I mean it pisses me off because
we're hearing reports that a lot of the
people who were doing the looting are
not from here police say they're bad
actors from out of town and I may tell
you the last thing Hollywood needs is
more bad actors
it's one thing to come here to break
into show business you can't break in
everything else but no I noticed the
looters very a multi-racial a lot of
they say white kids from the suburbs I
saw a kid on the news the other day
walked into an Adidas store and said I
loaded the wrong size could I get this
in a 10 I saw an up on Hollywood
Boulevard there were two Batman's
fighting over a fur coat what the [ __ ]
but no it just seemed like there's a
more of an effort to go after white
people stores forever21 is now no longer
21 it's at the mall right next to Bed
Bath & Beyond recognition but I don't
know by the time you watch this who
knows what the heck is gonna happen I
mean the news is happening so fast Trump
had to scramble from moment to moment to
make it worse did you see what it could
Trump I mean all week the first thing he
did beginning of the week had a call
group called with governor's from around
the country to tell them their week the
Whitney to dominate at least they think
that's what he said it was so hard to
hear because the signal from his
underground bunker was not good yeah
as soon as some [ __ ] started outside the
White House he went right to the bunker
five floors below ground right dead he
says he wasn't hiding he said I love
this he said it was more of an
inspection
oh yes an inspection and he didn't piss
himself he was watering his shoes I tell
you a deranged authoritarians and
bunkers always a winning combination
yeah Trump is now pitching himself for a
new sitcom but NBC called that's so
Hitler
[Applause]
well the shitty does I mean like the
peaceful protests were going on outside
the White House Americans doing what
they are allowed to do he dispersed them
this week with tear gas and then walks
across the street so we could hold up a
Bible and just see that holding the
Bible look like he never held a book
before which is entirely possible
so they say he's losing support I don't
know I would like to appeal directly to
the Trump fans and just remind them
hundred thousand dead the economy is
collapsing the soldiers in the street
cities are on fire
jared is guarding the White House with a
shotgun is America great enough for you
yet I mean is there any wonder couldn't
we have predicted this the FDA says
there is a shortage of the
antidepressant zoloft yeah well you know
combine that with the shortage of toilet
paper this is bad news if you're a sad
sack of [ __ ]
you